he was tested on a bench outside a
clinic i did feel humiliated did feel uh
stigmatized and you know again it's that
whole
pointing just like oh it's them so don't
worry just like if it
first appeared in i don't know schools
much like chicken pox it would have been
a completely different story
so nice and relaxed you know the drill
brighton may be the first area but the
uk as a whole is expected to run out of
monkey pox vaccines in two to three
weeks sky news understands there are
only around 5 000 left
people are already extremely worried
about it
people are feeling really marginalized
there's lots of equalities issues in
this as well
there's a risk that not only will monkey
pox become endemic
but it's going to further marginalize
people that are already experiencing
health barriers
cases in the uk are rising but not as
fast however the response to vaccinating
has been criticized as being too slow
the uk health and security agency blame
a global shortage and a worldwide surge
in demand for the vaccine they say
they're not in control of when the doses
become available or delivery
but there are claims communities outside
london have become an afterthought
and then there are other real hubs
around britain brighton manchester et
cetera who again have have been kind of
playing second fiddle and that again has
been a failure of political will to
centralize this process get the vaccine
orders properly done and start to ensure
you've got a proper vaccine program
while brighton has the most cases
outside london it could be more than a
month before vaccines arrive a huge risk
to public health adele robinson sky news
brighton